we're going to begin with some terrible
news it's a mass shooting in Alabama at
a sweet 16th birthday party four people
were killed and 28 others hurt most of
them were teenagers now this happened at
a dance studio in the city of Dadeville
Alabama Witnesses report that there were
multiple Shooters but so far police have
made no arrest in this case there have
already been 31 mass shootings just this
month in America and today is only the
17th day of April Omar villafrancas in
Dadeville Alabama with more on the story
Omar you certainly don't think of a
sweet 16 party as a deadly place but
that is a world we live in today
unfortunately good morning to you
good morning when people say it can
happen anywhere this is what they mean
Dadeville is small town USA population
just over 3 000. the venue where it
happened right behind me right on the
old Main Street that dance studio used
to be the old bank and for teenagers
this was probably the place to be this
weekend a birthday party everybody was
probably talking about it a sweet 16.
and then on Saturday the unthinkable
happened again
after Saturday night's deadly shooting
at mahogany Masterpiece Dance Center
ambulances police cars and parents
descended on the local hospital it was
peoples everywhere
running and yelling and crying and going
on I got shot right here
right here 18 year old Tanaya Cox was
shot three times she says she saw
multiple gunmen inside the dark Club I
just saw two in the bathroom and that's
where I ran police have not released any
details about the suspect or suspects
and would not say if anyone is in
custody for the attack we'll never be
the same Pastor Ben Hayes led a vigil
for the victims Sunday night most of the
kids there were from Dadeville this
impacted us a lot he says one of the
deceased is Senior Star athlete Phil
dowdell it was his sister's birthday
party their mother was also shot daudel
was just weeks from graduation and
recently committed to play football at
Jacksonville State next year
[Music]
says he was with dowdell at the party
but the two ran in opposite directions
when the shooting started
I'll stand right beside him
soon
I think he went right into it I went
absolutely
[Music]
police have been very tight-lipped about
this investigation there's a lot we do
not know we don't know how many suspects
they're looking for or how many suspects
are looking for if it's one two based on
what Witnesses are saying we don't know
what kind of gun was used we don't know
the motive but we're hoping to learn
more at a press conference later on this
morning Tony
yeah we know the result and that's
knowing a lot Omar thank you very much